After Fast Five turned the street racing franchise into a globe-trotting action blockbuster,
and Fast Six and Seven coasted off its momentum,
the newest combination of F words and numbers is here,
and they're still huffing off the fifth one's fumes.
Wow, these are getting really forced.
Buckle up for all the things you come to expect from the fast-chise:
Cars,
not cars,
"She just carjacked a submarine."
family,
and Vin Diesel mumble-growls.
"You made me happy."
"I choose to make my own fate."
"It's why I'm here."
And a sequel that really overestimates how much you remember from the last three.
"Ah yes, your brother Owen. Who could forget him, huh?"
I did.
"Elena."
Uhhh, who's that now?
"He's also linked to somebody I'd quite like to forget."
Wait, Djimon Hounsou was in these?
Look, I'm here for cars and butts in no particular order.
Don't overthink this, guys.
When somebody steals a something,
the government won't do anything about it because this guy said so.
"US government cannot sanction this operation in any way."
Now they're sending in a gang of petty thieves and street racers to get it back,
who became elite special forces so gradually,
you never stop to think about it.
You're carjackers! When did you turn into John Wick?
Join Tyrese, Ludacris, Kurt Russell,
and other characters who you refer to by their actors' names,
as they fade into the background of a buddy action comedy
starring Jason Statham and The Rock,
two meta-humans on opposite sides of the law,
responsible for every cool scene in the movie
and struggling not to give in to their raw animal lust for each other.
"All show, no go!"
"Oh, I got plenty of go!"
I am SO in for this spinoff.
When you're done having fun,
spend lots of time sitting on an airplane with the only guy who still takes these films seriously,
Vin Diesel.
As the movie whips from live-action cartoon where THIS happens
to serious drama where this happens.
"I'm gonna kill your son."
He's literally turned his back on his family,
and walked in to a different, much more boring movie with Charlize Theron.
She's Cipher, a hacker should really fire her assistant.
"My assistant actually came up with the hair."
"She just kinda out of nowhere said,
you should do, dreadlocks."
When she's not talking to her computer screen,
"What are you gonna do?"
"I spy with my little eye..."
"Minister of Defense."
she's whispering!
"Is that really a choice you wanna make?"
"I want you to learn."
"This is the consequence of that."
"Painful, but instructional memory."
"Ssssssssssshhhhhhhhhhhhh!"
Hey, Charlize, you're better than this.
Ratchet up the egos as The Rock and Vin Diesel
almost share screen time, as they sort of cross paths in voiceover,
"Hey, Dom."
"Hey, Hobbs."
in the distant background,
or in edits that make it seem like Vin wasn't the candy-ass male co-star The Rock called out on Instagram.
Come on guys, squash the beef!
You have so much in common, like,
uhhh, but you both, the, uhh,
hate sleeves!
Oh well, we'll always have Brazil.
"This is BRAZIL!"
So enjoy the latest installment of the franchise that's still chugging along,
no matter how much the co-stars hate each other,
how much the women are sidelined,
or how clearly they're trying to fill Paul Walker's shoes
with this dingus.
Just turn your brain off, and watch the cars go boom,
because they're counting on you to never ask for anything more.
You guys want to see Tyrese fight a spaceship in the next one or not?
"Rule number one: know your audience."
"Vin, for many years you've been the biggest supporter of strong women,
and I've always appreciated that about you throughout the year."
Michelle, are you okay?
Are you being held against your will? Blow a kiss if you want us to call the police.
Okay, I'm calling the cops.
Hey. Screen Junkies, ever wondered what Planet of the Apes' Caesar would be like in today's world?
What's his Tinder file like?
Teen to early 20s. I like long swings in the woods.
See more of our honest shenanigans
with Andy Serkis, Woody Harrelson, and the cast and director of War for the Planet of the Apes in our latest
Honest Interview now.